♪♪
>>> MY NAME IS DAVIS, AND I'M
STUPID.
>> HI.
I'M JOANN.
AND FOR AS LONG AS I CAN
REMEMBER, I'VE BEEN A STUPID
PERSON.
>> I'M TIM, AND MY PARENTS ARE
BOTH STUPID.
I'M STUPID, AND MY GRANDSON IS
STUPID.
>> NEARLY 1 IN 5 U.S. ADULTS
LIVE WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS OR
LEARNING DISABILITY.
>> AND WE ARE NOT THAT.
BELIEVE ME.
THEY CHECKED.
>> I'M JUST PLAIN STUPID.
>> I ALWAYS KNEW I WAS
DIFFERENT.
THINGS THAT WERE OBVIOUS TO
EVERYONE ELSE WERE ALWAYS VERY
COMPLICATED FOR ME.
>> JOKES HAVE TO BE EXPLAINED.
MOVIES HAVE TO BE EXPLAINED.
FOODS HAVE TO BE EXPLAINED.
SLOWLY.
>> I DON'T NEED THIS THING.
I JUST THOUGHT IT SOUNDED COOL.
I GUESS THAT'S STUPID.
>> MOST PEOPLE, LIKE ME, GO
THEIR WHOLE LIVES WITHOUT EVER
KNOWING THEY'RE STUPID, BUT
WE'RE EVERYWHERE.
WE DRIVE YOUR BUSES.
WE RUN COMPANIES.
>> I WRITE LAWS.
>> AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
I DO.
>> I FOUND OUT I WAS STUPID
WALKING FULL SPEED INTO A GLASS
WINDOW.
A STAINED GLASS WINDOW.
>> SARCASM JUST SOUNDS LIKE LIES
TO ME.
>> BEING STUPID IS NOT A CHOICE.
>> IT'S NOT A CHOICE.
>> IT'S A CHOICE.
>> JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE A STUPID
PERSON DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T
HAVE A VOICE.
SO, GET OUT THERE.
>> GET OUT THERE.
>> AND VOTE.
>> LET YOUR VOICE BE HEARD.
>> VOTE.
>> I'M STUPID, AND I VOTED.
>> I VOTE.
AND I AM VERY STUPID.
>> WAIT.
THIS AIN'T MY GRANDSON.
>> MY STUPID VOTE COUNTS AS MUCH
AS ANYBODY ELSE.
>> AND SOMETIMES WAY MORE, LIKE
IN MY COUNTY.
>> SO DON'T LET THEM STOP YOU.
>> DON'T LET THEM CONFUSE YOU.
>> SOMEBODY WILL SAY SOMETHING,
AND THEN SOMEBODY WILL SAY
SOMETHING ELSE.
IT'S JUST TOO MUCH.
>> YOU CAN VOTE.
YOU CAN BUY A GUN.
>> YOU CAN BUY ALL THE GUNS.
>> I WATCH ONE CHANNEL, AND I
GET SO MAD.
>> MY SON'S WIFE IS A SMART
PERSON.
SHE'S TEARING US APART.
>> VOTE.
>> GET OUT THERE.
>> VOTE EVERY DAY IF YOU HAVE
TO.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE THEY ASK IF
YOU'RE STUPID.
>> NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO LEARN
THINGS THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO.
>> I VOTE FOR DONKEYS.
BUT SOMETIMES I LIKE ELEPHANTS.
>> I WANT A CANDIDATE THAT
SMILES AT ME.
>> THE COMPUTER SCREEN SAYS
PROVE YOU'RE NOT A ROBOT, SO I
CUT MYSELF.
>> SOMEBODY SAID -- AND I'M
LIKE, IS THAT REAL?
>> MY SCREEN TIME IS 14 HOURS A
DAY.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW I HAVE
ANOTHER PHONE.
>> VOTE.
>> DANCE.
>> FOR A TALL MAN.
>> VOTE.
BECAUSE THEY GIVE YOU A STICKER
AND YOU CAN PUT IT ANYWHERE.
>> WAIT, THIS IS MY GRANDSON.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]